the u.s secretary of state has defended
washington's backing of the saudi-led
coalition's bombing campaign in yemen
it comes after a senate vote last week
to withdraw support
mike pompeo says its continuation though
is a way to ensure
just peace and to alleviate suffering
from that
war-torn country the senators who voted
i say they want to end the bombing in
yemen
and support human rights but we really
need to think about who's human rights
if you truly care about your many lives
you'd support the saudi-led effort to
prevent yemen from turning
into a puppet state of the corrupt
british islamic republic of iran
the way to alleviate the yemeni people's
suffering isn't to prolong the conflict
by handicapping our partners in the
fight but by giving the saudi-led
coalition the support needed to defeat
iranian-backed rebels and ensure just
peace donald trump's arms deals with
saudi arabia are expected to total
around 350 billion dollars over a decade
and apart from
armed supplies and military equipment
washington also provides red with
logistics and intelligence
next this morning our senior
correspondent murad gazdev looks deeper
into the u.s secretary of state's
recent comments the united states
makes no secret of what it stands for
freedom justice democracy
and saudi arabia the white house stands
firm on that even if the senate is
having second thoughts
voting to end u.s support for
riyadh's endless war in yemen
saudi arabia's bloody war in yemen
world's worst humanitarian disaster
the horrific war in yemen saudi-led
quagmire we are helping
saudi arabia drop bombs on churches
on weddings we all want this conflict to
end
if you truly care about your many lives
you'd support the saudi-led effort to
prevent yemen from turning
into a puppet state of the corrupt
british islamic republic
of iran as opposed to becoming a puppet
of the free and fair saudi arabia
but what do we know saudis have waged a
four-year war against houthi rebels
who they call terrorists that has turned
yemen
into a humanitarian catastrophe worse
even than syria four in five yemeni
civilians
24 out of 28 million
need aid to survive three in five or
20 million either on the brink or
already starving but mr pompeo
has a solution the united states has
given more than two billion dollars to
help the yemeni people
since the start of the conflict and
saudi arabia
has given over 500 million dollars in
2018 alone and has pledged an additional
500 million dollars this year
which works out to about two dollars
per hungry civilian per month from
washington
but that's for the cameras you know
where the
real money is guns oh yes
guns three billion dollars 533
million dollars 525
million dollars that's peanuts for you
you've
increased it peanuts she says 12.5
billion dollars in
arms that the us is selling saudi arabia
is peanuts what does that make the aid
then
but mr pompeo is adamant if
a little bit rabid in his support for
saudi arabia
and gun sales if we truly care about
saudi lives you'd want to stop iran back
houthis from launching missiles
into riyadh amazing how you can
twist and turn reality on its head
rather than protecting your many
civilians from saudi arabia
he's protecting saudi arabia from
starving yemeni civilians
brilliant speaking of protecting saudi
lives
there is at least one life that
washington didn't seem so concerned
about
mr hashoji was the victim of a brutal
and premeditated killing
planned and perpetrated by officials of
the state of saudi arabia
riyadh has brushed off accusations that
the royal family had anything to do with
it saying it was
a rogue operation and it seems
washington was
all too happy to support this
explanation here we see the real
relationship
which uh brought trillions and trillions
of dollars
in profit to u.s oil companies the banks
the military corporations
the trump government and usually not
just the trump government but the
administrations in washington democrat
and republican
serve the interests of those big banks
and corporations
and so maintaining that relationship and
with all that it means
for profit and power and empire the
interest of empire
that's the priority not the lives of the
people of yemen or the people of saudi
arabia or the people of venezuela or for
that matter the people of the united
states
you